good morning from New Zealand where I'm
currently currently staying for a couple
of weeks uh but uh wherever you're in
the wherever you are in the world uh uh
welcome
so as Logan said I wanted to talk a
little bit about kind of multilingual
data science
and hopefully I don't need to
like the labor too much why this is
important
because I think it's pretty obvious that
like every team has to deal with
multiple languages because regardless of
whether you use r or python or Julia
you have to use SQL as well like there's
no getting away from it I we kind of
strongly believe that there's no way to
it would be awesome if we could all just
standardize on one single language but
that's never going to happen so rather
than like threading about it rather than
worrying about it rather than letting us
stress us out like let's embrace it
let's embrace the different strengths
and weaknesses of various languages and
really think about how can we help teams
of folks using different tools work
together as effectively as possible
so today I kind of want to talk about
three things uh the first as Logan said
is to share a little bit about of my
love for ah R is like a weird language
it's definitely got some quirks uh
things that don't make sense but it also
is a few things that seem surprising
when you first hit them if you've used a
language like python particularly you're
going to see these things and think wow
that is really really weird
and I want to talk a little bit about
about some of that weirdness and why
it's not just it's not wrong it's just
different and in fact it leads to some
pretty cool and surprising features
did I want to talk a little bit about uh
the sort of Journey from our studio to
posit like why do we change our names
what's kind of our mission as our
company and then dive into some of the
tools that we are really working on
currently that are again not about that
idea of how do we help multilingual
teams work together as effectively as
possible
so I'm going to start with three
surprising features of R in these things
are surprising because when you hit them
at first
they they might not seem like features
they might seem like bucks
or and they're certainly going to feel
very weird coming from just about any
other programming language so I want to
kind of highlight some of those talk
about like why
they're actually cool and interesting
and uh show you a little bit of our code
along the way
so for context uh the job of me and my
team primarily is a developer tidy verse
which is a collection of our packages
that make data science fast fluent and
fun
but we also develop tools that software
Engineers use tools for package
development in our things like roxigen 2
for inline documentation test that for
unit testing package down or beautiful
packages and use this for automating
every part of the package development
process that you possibly can
so all our we spend a lot of our time
kind of thinking about user interfaces
thinking about how we can make data
analysis as pleasant as enjoyable as
fluent as possible for data scientists
and similarly how can we do the same
thing for kind of when you switch hats
from your data scientist your software
engineering pad how can you help how can
we help you make robust reliable
packages it's easier easily and
painlessly as possible
so I'm going to show you a little r code
shortly I'm going to motivate that code
what I'm going to do is make the scatter
plot
so this scatter plot is on the x-axis
you can see we've got distance and on
the y-axis we've got speed and then
we've got a bunch of dots
in each of these dots represents a root
of a flight in the continental U.S so An
Origin and destination uh we've got some
data about those flights which I'll show
you shortly what we've done is
aggregated each route to look at the
distance and the average speed and we
see this kind of interesting pattern
which I'll talk a little bit about later
but what I want to talk about first is
how do we get to this plot
so we're going to start with some data
so we've got about 300 000 rows of
flight data uh you know not a
particularly large data set but not
nothing either
we've got information about when the
flight's Departed
both when it's scheduled to the part and
when it actually departed when it
arrived uh who floor flew it which
airline uh what the flight number was
what the plain tail number was Etc
uh with the time it's been in the year
the distance and so on
if you look carefully
because there's no variable here speed
we've got the time and the distance but
we don't have the speed so our first
task is going to be to compute that
and to do that we're going to use a
function from the D player package
called mutate
the Java mutate is to create new
variables and so we're going to say we
want to create a new variable called
speed
and we're going to compute that variable
that's just the speed is just the
distance in miles divided by the time in
hours to give us miles per hour now here
airtime is a minute so we just have to
do a little conversion there
so this should mostly look
straightforward there's a bit of weird
syntax here uh this thing is called the
pipe and it's the easiest to pronounce
them I'll come back to the pipe a couple
of times in this talk because it's a
really important and interesting idea
and uh but for now just in your head
when you see this read this as Dean so
we take the flights data then we mutate
it to add a variable called speed which
is this function of distance air times
the next thing we want to do is we want
to Summarize each route and a root is a
combination of origin and destination
so the first thing we're going to know
is we're going to declare that like this
is our unit of analysis we're going to
say we want to group by the origin and
destination and then we want to
summarize it to compute these three
variables where it can be the distance
the speed and then just count the number
of flights
now you might kind of wonder when you're
like thinking about this over here
you've got a flight route it's between
two airports
shouldn't the distance always be the
same
hopefully yes like obviously the speed
is going to change because sometimes
planes take longer but hopefully that
distance should always be the same here
I'm just using mean as an easy way to
like get that if you're doing a real
analysis here you might also want to
compute like the standard deviation of
distance because if that's not zero
that's telling you something pretty
weird about what's going on with this
Air Force
so we've got the distance we compute the
average distance the average speed
removing any missing values and then we
also get the the now count the number of
observations and this is good because
you know whenever you're doing an
aggregate you want to know the number of
observations you're aggregating over
because you know there's hardly any
observations there's going to be a lot
of variability there and that probably
not that interesting to look at and so
in fact that's the next thing I'm going
to do is I'm going to say just give me
the rows give me the routes that have at
least 10 flights 10 observations
so now if summer we've added that
variable we've grouped it we've
summarized it filtered it now we want to
turn it into a clock
so we're going to switch from the D ply
package to the ggplot2 package and the
key idea of ggplot2 is that the
visualization is just a mapping between
variables in your data the things that
you can perceive which in ggplot2 we
call Aesthetics and we use AES for short
so here we're saying we want to create a
plot that is going to map the X position
on the plots to distance the Y position
to speed and then we're going to
visualize each observation with a point
giving us a scatter plot
so Gigi part 2 that it's a little bit
different to other planning systems that
uses this idea called the grammar of
Graphics it doesn't give you this canned
state of named Graphics like scatter
plot linebot pie chart Etc it gives you
these Primitives you map your variables
the things that you can perceive you
pick the geom or geometric object you
want to display them with and then ggp.2
that's the risk
and so that gives us this plot
you can see there's like a pretty sort
of pronounced curve here
uh short flights this speed is basically
dominated by takeoff and Landing which
are much slower and the longer a flight
is the more time it can spin it's kind
of optimal but the more time it can
spend like the optimal cruising speed
and the more likely the airliners to use
a bigger faster plane to travel
there's one group of weird points which
uh kind of don't follow this pattern I
looked at these just a little bit uh
these are a bit weird because these are
to ear ports that are not in the
continental United States which is a
little bit surprising because that's
what was supposed to be the only thing
in this data set so again real dare
analysis you want to drill into that a
little bit more but you know very very
common part of the process you create a
plot and you see something weird and it
represents some data quality problem
that you're going to want to cycle back
to and figure out what's up
okay so that
very very quickly is a little bit of our
code that does something you know small
but realistic in a data analysis
what makes us tick
so the first thing I want to talk about
was to dive into a little bit details
just that that mutates function
and to do that I'm going to create a
data frame that just contains those two
variables we care about distance and
AirTime in just the first six
observations
now if you've never seen our code before
two kind of tricks first this arrow
thing that's the less than Dash is RS
primary assignment operator that's what
you use to create variables and then
Oops I messed up my
transition there uh
this Dart does not represent calling a
method it's just a regular symbol and a
function name so if you're coming from
python or many other languages like Java
uh it's going to take you a while to get
your hit around this you're not calling
the frame a method of the data object
you're calling this data dot frame
function and that's the function in R we
use to create data frames which is the
data structure used to store rectangular
data
and then just going to recapitulate the
code where you saw before I'm going to
take that data frame then I'm going to
mutate it Computing the speed
and the pipe here is just syntactic
sugar all the pipe does it takes the
thing on the left hand side and puts it
into the first argument of the function
on the right hand side of the pipe
so it's just syntactic sugar
for this
so here it is with the pipe if I rewrite
it without the pipe
we now see that DF is just the first
argument to mutate
the pipes is this really nice feature
because so often when you're working on
a data analysis you do these multiple
Transformations the pipe just allows us
to write that linearly come back to that
another once more before we're done here
the next thing that's kind of
interesting about this code is inside
this function we refer to distance and
air time just like our regular variables
that you've just defined with
assignments but they're not regular here
but the variables that exist inside this
data frame
and you'll see this pattern a lot in r
that many many functions allow you to
write code
that works kind of inside a data frame
as if you assigned the individual
columns individual variables of a data
frame the top level variables in your
program
in kind of even crazier
you can actually mix both variables
inside the data frame in variables
outside the data frame
now this absolutely can lead to really
like confusing and hard to read code but
most of the time it allows you to really
elegantly
describe what you're doing to the
variables in your data State without
having to have a bunch of additional
syntax to say oh this variable is inside
that data frame this bill inside that
data frame well most of the time it's
like these variables are all inside the
data frame and I've got to repeat the
name of the data frame many many times
or use some other kind of Sentinel to
say hey this is something going on
inside this data
so why does this work
this is kind of the first surprising
feature of our
and that is in his first class abstract
syntax trees and first class
environments
so what does that mean so every
programming language has abstracts and
textures and has environments it has
every programming language has some way
to represent the structure of code
typically in some kind of tree form
after you've like fully passed it out
and dealt with all the operator
precedence issues and some way to
associate names with values which is
what uh in our we call environments now
some languages a few languages are first
class abstract syntax trees this is kind
of the famous thing about lists right
that you can actually program on code
you can program code because there's a
representation a programmable
representation of codes so R has that
and additionally it has first class
environments you can actually look at
the way that names are bound to values
introspect on that and modify that
and as far as I know that is unique in
the spectrum of all uh programming
languages it's almost certainly some
programming language that I don't know
about that does it but none of the
mainstream programming environmental
even the sort of weirder ones that are
popular today have this feature
in this definitely makes our code like
harder to optimize but it also gives
others like unparalleled ability to
create domain-specific languages for
solving problems and we can apply that
sort of so well to data source that's
what gives us the tools like deeply and
ggplot2 that allow us to kind of turn
our data science forward so data center
words into code in a way that's quite
generally Pretty Natural
and it also what gives us the ability to
create tools like DB player so DB player
is a d player back end a back end for D
player is just you has the same syntax
but as the computation in some other way
so when you're using D ply you're going
to connect to a database as the DB might
suggest to you and you're going to write
D player code just like you normally do
and DB player is going to convert that
to SQL so in this case it's going to
generate the SQL with a CTE that does
that computes the speed variable and
then a group summary
this isn't exactly you know the sequel
you might write by hand in particular
with kind of very conservatively quoted
every single possible variable name just
to make sure it's not a special name
inside the data frame and you might do a
few things different you might give the
various informative names but overall
like TV Fighters are pretty good job
and it does this in a pretty like
implementation of DB player is still
pretty crazy to me because it does this
by defining a special environment where
like mean instead of like calculator
mean actually generates some SQL text
that then gets inlined into this query
this is one of the my kind of personal
favorite packages that I've worked on
but lots there are lots of other uses of
this in r as well just two I wanted to
highlight or the ompr package for mixed
integer programming uh here you can
Define relationships between integer
variables Define like objectives and
constraints and then allow ompr to go
away and like solve that problem for you
another package Greta design
amazing statistics
it uses a syntax like really inspired by
what you might have seen in the Bayesian
statistics class so here I'm just
defining a very simple linear model of
Bayesian linear model we have defining a
pi distribution for my intercept and
slope describing how the mean is a
function of the intercept and the slope
and the data how I expect the
distribution of the predictor to be a
normal distribution would that mean I
just computed and that standard
deviation defined earlier and I can go
away
invisibility to kind of tailor uh the
way that our code looks to match other
environments other other ways of other
notational systems I think is really
really powerful and really really cool
and again I can do that because it has
these first class abstracts and text
trees first class environments gives you
this incredible ability to create domain
specific languages that solve some small
part of the data science process
foreign
next I wanted to talk a little bit more
about the pipe
because if you look at this pipeline
that I showed you earlier and kind of
squint your eyes a little bit
you might say oh well couldn't we just
write that using like method chaining
with python like it's very very similar
right
just basically changing that pipe for a
DOT
at each point
but there's something that's profoundly
different about that pipe and that is at
each point each element of that pipeline
can come from a different package
and the thing that makes this work
is kind of surprising and mind-blowing
and when I first encountered R took me
several years to really understand
and that is an R methods belong to
functions
not classes
so I kind of want to don't want to go
into all the details of this but if you
kind of think about object-oriented
systems every object-ground system has
this kind of like functions that you
call in classes that you use and the
methods or the intersection of them
right you can think of it sort of a 2d
table that you've got functions and
you've got classes in most programming
languages kind of organize the oop
system like row wise and are kind of
organizers that column wise
well obviously very that's a a great
caricature of what's going on but I
think that that's kind of it's like a
orthogonal way of thinking about
object-oriented programming
and
for a long time this is pretty quirky
like two languages use this commonless
in r
but recently in other programming
languages come along that also uses a
style of programming language and that's
Juliet
and I think that's one of the things
that Julia folks really attributes to
the ease of reusing code and Julia is
this style of object I am programming it
just seems to fit particularly with kind
of like scientific Computing and data
science so well
so the consequences of this are pretty
profound uh this like ability
component of that pipeline can come from
a different package it means in ah we
don't need these like really big kind of
Monolithic packages like pandas like
psychic learn that when you're
assembling a pipeline you can assemble
pieces from all over the place which
means uh for the life of software
developers is much easier because they
can develop these small reusable pieces
in isolation without having to consider
this giant other package
Okay so we've talked about two weird
things about two surprising things about
R the first one first class abstract
injectories and environments which
allows you to create these domain
specific languages the data science uh
we have the fact that methods belong to
functions not classes which allows us to
write pipelines that combine tools from
many many different places
and the last thing I want to talk about
is kind of how to describe a kind of
crazy at this diet and that's like when
you install a package and ah generally
like 99 of the time you just install it
into some like a global repository of
packages on your computer
because when you're working with ah most
approach Pro don't need a virtual
environment and most people using ah can
just share the same step the packages
across all of their projects and Things
by and large just work
now obviously if you really care about
long-term reproducibility you have to do
more than that you are going to have to
capture your exact version of your
dependencies using some you know virtual
invite Tool uh an r one is called RM
um developer one of my colleagues but
there's plenty of other options as well
and the reason this is the case
is that package development is really
highly centralized and I think it's easy
to think of centralization generally as
kind of a bad thing or at least that
that's kind of the way that uh
The Tick is currently trending is we
want to distribute things as much as
possible
but there are some big advantages to
exercise centralization and so I just
want to kind of briefly compare like
cran uh the comprehensive archive
Network which probably
supplies like 99 of our packages
installed in the Wild versus Pi Pi which
maybe does 80 of the package private
package that installs in the wild
and the thing that's like fundamentally
different about crayon compared to Pi Pi
and pretty much every other modern kind
of software distribution tool then
enforces package compatibility
so at any moment in time every package
and cran must work with all of the other
current version of all of its
dependencies and crap
and no lie this is a huge amount of work
because it makes life much much harder
for developers if you're developing a
python package you can easily set up a
GitHub action that automatically deploys
the pipi whenever you you know whenever
you do a release
whenever you tag you can completely 100
automate that process and it just works
in R the process
is much harder we've got to go through
this the system is like I don't know 80
automated and 20 of human audited
and if you make a breaking change to
your package it's your responsibility to
communicate that to all of the people
who use your package on crap
and that's a lot of work
but it comes with like this big payoff
for users that by and large they can
just grab a bunch of packages from cram
and they all work
and I think this is maybe one of the
reasons that uh cran is so much smaller
than Pipi uh obviously there are other
reasons like the uh python generally the
number of Python program is the most
much bigger than the number of our
programmers but I think this this it's
not easy to uh
public is not as easy to publish a
package with r and that leads to fewer
packages but they tend to be easier for
people to work with
the other kind of last interesting fact
is that the definition of a package in R
is really baked into the language itself
it's included in the standard Library
includes this talk or command check
which runs a bunch of standardized
checks and specs of documentation and
tests and stuff in various ways and
that's being that the uh that's been
there for day one basically of our you
know day 300 or something but very very
early on really key part of the success
of R has been the ability to like
distribute binaries that are built on
the centralized Crown repository and
people have been able to install these
on Windows for years and years and years
I think that's one reason
uh that's the the distribution of
operating systems is quite different
between R and python because I think
something like 80 of our users are on
Windows uh the other 20 roughly split
between Mac and Linux and I look this up
but I've already forgotten what it was
for python but I think it's much much
lower maybe like 40 of python users on
Windows I think just one of these kind
of other differences in the language
ecosystems
so those are three things uh R has top
level
uh first class abstract Industries and
environments uh our methods belong to
functions not classes and most users
don't need a virtual environment or many
users don't need a virtual environment
because package development is highly
centralized
I think hopefully these are three things
that uh as a python user or as users of
some other language you like wow that's
that's that's odd
but hopefully I've also shown you that
these have some pretty cool consequences
as well and so when you see them I hope
you think not just like oh this is oh
this is weird and wrong but like oh this
is different and interesting
thank you
now I do like I don't know I spend like
90 of my life
and uh I do like everything you know I
just did a secret Santa for my family
where I broke up the whole thing in ours
you know the emails automatically but
there's lots of other people who work
for the same company that I do
and the goal of our company
is to make cool our packages but to
really have a positive impact generally
on data science
and uh technical communication so I want
to talk a little bit just briefly I like
I don't think people are talking about
their companies is that interesting
General so I want to go through this
pretty quickly but it is important
because I think this is a this is pretty
big pretty big change for us and I
wanted to talk about I think our goals
are like pretty cool and I'm you know
really on board with them
so you may have heard of our studio
before we recently changed our name
deposit uh basically the reflect the
fact that we already are a multilingual
company many or all of our pro products
already support multiple Banks
but it's obviously really really hard to
sell people on buying a product that
supports Python and Julia and whatever
comes along in the future when literally
the first words in the pet in the
company name is the name of a
programming language
that's what that's why we changed that
night
and so you've probably heard of some of
the products that uh
makes for example the r Studio IDE which
is very very popular in the ER community
tidy verse which you just talked about
shiny which is a tool for making
interactive web apps and our markdown
which is a tool for making
static documents mostly set up documents
and all up out of about 100 engineers at
posit about 40 of them were full-time
open source software and many others
work part of their time as well so posit
really is an open source fundamentally
and open source company
in our mission deposit
is not to make a ton of money our
mission is to develop this like
long-term durable trustworthy
instruments that can really help the
advancement of Science and data science
like our goal is to be around for a
really long time so that we can tackle
problems that potentially take decades
to solve
so how do we do that
well first of all we're a PBC and a b
Corp what does that mean
well it's a kind of like traditional C
Corp or LLC basically the fundamental
responsibility encoded in the corporate
charter is to maximize value for
shareholders to make as much money as
possible for the people who own some
part of your company
the idea of the B Corp is to recognize
firstly that there are people who might
you might want to think about who don't
own some other company and that may be
the best thing to do is not just to
optimize the amount of money
and so the idea of the B Corp is to
recognize that there are other
communities like the broader open source
data science community that we really
care about
and it's like that is that caring that
importance is fundamentally baked into
our Charter as a company
the other component is is like we want
to remain independent which means we're
closely closely held we're private uh
we're never going to IPO we're never
going to be acquired by someone our goal
is to be independent and we do that by
being profitable and we're profitable
because we sell software
so kind of four main things we sell
connect which really helps kind of get
the hands of we get data science out of
the hands of data scientists into like a
decision either the decision makers or
your company through like reports and
emails and apps or to other parts of
your organization through apis
workbench helps teams of data scientists
work effectively together particularly
utilizing uh shared high power
computational infrastructure
package manner helps make sure all of
your dependencies are in line with your
corporate policy and everyone's using
the same version the same place and then
surprise posit Cloud helps you do those
things same things but in the cloud
so to finish up I want to talk about a
few of the open source tools that we're
currently working on that are
specifically designed to support
multiple languages
and the first one I want to talk about
is quarter which is a tool designed to
help you publish stuff to make documents
the key idea of quarto is you're going
to start with some document there's two
types of documents you might start with
you might start with something like a
Jupiter notebook where you have text
where you have code and you have the
results of that code
or you might start with something like
an um more like an R markdown document
now a quarter markdown document that
just has the text and the code and you
need to run that code and their code can
be in python or r or Julia or you know
pretty much anything
in both cases we're going to end up with
a markdown document markdown is a really
great we think like format because it's
a text format it's easily difficult
you can share it with people uh easy to
write by hand eat it by hand if you need
to
but even more importantly than that
markdown gets you into the pandok
ecosystem
and if you haven't heard of pandok
before it's a really amazing tool for
doing document Transformations basically
and by building that type of pan dog
that allows Corto to produce things like
Word documents and PowerPoint
presentations and PDFs and HTML files
you can even publish kind of fully round
trip uh the publisher a notebook from
the end of it if your input is something
else or even some some cases it's useful
to kind of round trip because some of
the tools I'll talk about shortly
so quarter like helps you turn your
words and your code into some document
that you can share with others it also
provides tools for when you've got like
a bunch of documents and you want to
convey some bigger story whether that's
through a website or a blog or a book
now if you are an eye user this might
look kind of familiar and that's no
surprise because quarto was very much
inspired by our 10 years of experience
with our master
which really I think convinced us at
this core idea of literate programming
for data science is the right approach
that you want to be able to create
reproducible documents that when you
when the data changes you can re-run
your code combine it with your pros and
get a new word document or HTML page or
PowerPoint slide
but in the time that since our Market
was created like the number of languages
used for data scientists increased and
continues to increase and so the and so
while like our markdon did support other
languages you could you could absolutely
use Python inside of our markdown today
you still have to have R installed and
that's not like super compelling right
if you're a python user and you want to
create a nice document you don't want to
install office so the goal of quarter is
this ground up reimagining we're going
to make it fully multi-language fully
multi-engine so regardless of what
language you're you're doing your data
science and whether it's r or python or
Jupiter or something that doesn't even
exist today quarto is going to support
that quarter is going to be the engine
helps you combine your pros and your
code and your results to create some
beautiful documents to share with others
and generally one of the goals of Corto
is to help make it easier to write
scientifically to do scientific writing
inside a markdown and some of you might
have seen this kind of humorous
depiction of the tools you might
currently use to write scientific
documents so you know you can start with
you might use word
which starts really simple but rapidly
gets very very complex as soon as you
add in citations or complex figures
gives really really complicated really
really quickly
you could of course use latex which like
starts hard and stays hard uh once you
once you've got the ability to like do a
later document you've mastered the art
of like Googling for latex syntax uh
you know it doesn't get that much harder
but very very hard and not accessible to
most people
so markdown is a great way to start but
if you're using markdown for scientific
writing you kind of rapidly hit some
limitations like you're gonna have to
bring your own tooling for combining
multiple files you're gonna have to
figure out some new syntax with the
various types of things you want to do
in scientific writing and so the idea of
quarter or the aspiration for quarto is
to really start as easy as word and only
get a little bit harder over time
and quota does that by building a bunch
of extensions on top of pandok
extensions for things like citations so
you can just like copy and paste a DOI
and and you automatically get a nicely
formatted citation Rich Crawford cross
references between longer documents
equations using latex math complex
diagrams and multi-fix panels all of
these things that you need when writing
creating scientific documents
and the thing that's great about all of
these things is they're built on top of
this extension mechanism provided by
panda
and the neat thing about this is that
this extension mechanism is written on
top of the abstract syntax tree of the
the markdown document so written on top
of the semantics of the document not on
the text format so if you've ever tried
to do some of these things introduce new
syntax by hand with regular Expressions
it starts off like it's doable if you
want to add one extension maybe if you
want to add two you start to hit all of
these like weird edge cases so it's very
very hard to get from the correct
so pandok provides this really cool
extension mechanism like the kind of
downside of the extension mechanism is
you're going to have to learn a little
bit about lure uh it's a relatively rare
programming language but it's designed
to be used in exactly this situation
embed it inside other tools so if you've
used any other programming language
before whether a Zara or python or
something else you're going to be able
to pick up lure very very quickly
and then on top
of those pan duck extensions quarter
provides an extension mechanism that
makes it really easy to document your
extension to publish your extension to
share your extension of other people so
once you've figured out how to do this
the whole Community can build on top of
it
so what are some examples of quarto used
today uh personally I use it for pretty
much everything I write all the books I
write around quarto but in the python
ecosystem you might be interested in
these two projects that use it where's
McKinney's python for data analysis uses
it and the Practical deep learning
course from Fast IAS as well
and if you want to see more examples
there are many many more of course on
the quarter website
so that's going to peaked your interest
a little bit in quarto I highly
recommend uh let's talk by my colleague
Tom Marks a reproducible Publications
with python quarto which is going to be
in two days time two hours ago
okay so that's quarto which is primarily
about publishing documents and I kind of
talked about like mostly static
documents but it also allows you it also
has support for a particularly
um
the preservable JavaScript so you can do
like within page interactivity
but there are some tasks that you need
kind of like full interactive you want
to be able to drag a slider that turns
issues a queries or database or
retrieves some data that fits a model
and shares the result back
and for that sort of need
we have Shining so shiny was originally
an r package and now it has a python
division as well and it's really
designed to create interactive apps and
dashboards so that you can help
decision makers inside your organization
like see what's going on with the data
sets
so I'm going to start with a very
simple example
from shiny life
so shiny live I'll just make that a
little bigger for you shiny live uh is
powered by the kind of magic of iodide
and wasm so here I'm running like Python
and pie shiny fully in the browser uh so
here I've got a little pie shiny app and
you can see as I change the slider that
the histogram changes
so how does pie shining work well
there's two main components first of all
we're going to define the UI so here
we've got a page that contains a sidebar
that's the sky which contains a slider
and a main panel that contains a plot
so shiny kind of separates out the the
view of the page from the interactivity
and the interactivity is provided by the
server function which uses some
decorators to annotate this function
so this function is called histogram
which lines up with the by convention
lines up with the name of this plot in
the UI so when this function runs it's
going to automatically uh
draw the histogram and that histogram is
going to appear in that main plane
and the thing that's neat about shiny is
that you don't have to be
actually to clear the dependencies like
like shiny is going to see that this
plot is using the number of this
interactive slider for the number of
bins
and so whenever this changes shiny is
going to automatically update that plot
so this is a very very simple example uh
shiny can also do very complex things
I'm just going to show you this uh kind
of cool
example that my colleague Joe Ching put
together for pi data NYC so here we have
a 3D chart
and the kind of cool thing about this
this gratuitously cool thing about this
is I can control that
by moving my hand around
in the webcam right to my hand position
feeds that into the shiny plot shiny and
rotates the plot
so I don't really I don't want to go
into the details of that at all but just
to show you that uh the shine the power
of shiny is
it goes a very very long way
so shiny has this kind of dual design
for both data scientists and software
Engineers uh if you're a data scientist
you can start creating web apps
interactive web apps with like very
little HTML CSS or JavaScript skills it
uses this reactive programming model uh
which makes interactively easy to get
start with and it builds on how many
years of shiny for um seeing what data
scientists actually want to do
but it's also designed for software
Engineers so if you know HTML and CSS
and JavaScript you can use that and you
get to like learn about this really kind
of amazing programming Paradigm good
reactive
and just in a very very conceptually
reactive programming is really all about
creating a dag a directed acyclic graph
from your inputs to your outputs and
that what shiny does is when one of your
inputs changes it knows how to
automatically
invalidate all of the things Downstream
and recompute them as needed
and this like this reactive model is
relatively simple but surprisingly Rich
it gives you all of this kind once you
master the idea it gives you all the
stuff kind of for free
so the last thing I want to talk about
today uh is better which is a set of
tools for iron python for mlrs so that
of course begs the question of what is
email Ops and there are a lot of
competing and conflicting definitions uh
in play today but kind of our framing of
ml Ops is a set of practices to deploy
and maintain email models in production
both reliably and efficiently
and here we're thinking mostly about
kind of human efficiency how do we make
this as easy as possible for the data
scientists to do
so vetiver stays out of the initials and
model building process where you collect
data and understand and clean and
visualize it and try a bunch of models
and evaluate them you you bring your own
whether that's XJ x g boost and R or
psychic learner python better is going
to support you no matter what you use
vetiver starts to play when you want to
get that model into production
and if you're going to put a model in
production we really believe the first
thing you need to do is version that
model and that's really important
because it allows you to track how it
changes over time and if you
accidentally scroll up you can easily
revert to a previous measure
then veterans can help you deploy the
model uh in the most General case this
is basically developing a Docker can
creating a Docker container that runs a
server that exposes a Json API that
other services can hit with data and get
predictions back out
now if you're using a posit connect our
tool for uh that helps data scientists
communicate with other in the
organization this all gets handled
behind the hood and you can deploy your
model with like one line of code
and importantly this doesn't just deploy
the model it also deploys some
documentation and currently the
documentation for the API like how you
actually use it but in the future
there's also it's going to support
publishing uh documentation about the
model itself through the popular model
card framework
and then finally you're going to want to
monitor that model and because you've
got all these versions of the previous
model very easy to track what's going on
what's Happening to your model
if that sounds interesting I highly
recommend attending the talk by my
colleague is Isabel Zimmerman uh
practical ml Ops have been our models
which is happening in one day two and a
half hours ago
so
that's kind of a lot of content to kind
of sum up briefly uh like yes R is a
weird programming language and some of
the things that I think I truly believe
are really amazing features of R are
going to seem very surprising at first
if you're coming from pretty much any
other programming language they
certainly took Mia back at first when I
started using art many many years ago
but they they just give you like so much
so they allow you to do so many cool
things that you can't do another project
they really encourage you to look at r
with an open mind and think wow like
what can I learn from our what can I do
in our other programming languages can't
do like what's interesting not just like
we what's weird
so the company I work for was formerly
called rstudio now called posit is not
just about ah it hasn't really been just
about R for a number of years now and
we've changed our name to reflect that
and you know I just want to kind of
recognize that I've shown you three
tools that three open source tools that
we're working on currently quarto uh for
publishing mostly static documents shiny
for publishing interactive web apps and
document web apps and dashboards vetiver
to support your ml Ops process we are
working on these tools to embrace this
reality that most data science teams are
not unilingual most data science teams
are multilingual and we want to build
tools that help everyone work together
as effectively as possible
thank you
heavily this was awesome this was this
is such an incredibly uh packed talk
with with a very uh wide array of useful
information so I appreciate it the demos
were also super cool the the
visualization that was showing around
your hand was was awesome
um we've got a ton of questions um so I
think let's just Dive Right into some of
these uh that came up during the talk
um
so we'll go to Ron's question first Ron
was saying that you mentioned that our
functions don't need singles hopefully
I'm pronouncing that right in order to
get their arguments um as asts unlike
say Julia where macro calls our prefix
with the out sign does this have
downsides for readability
yeah yeah absolutely like there's a
massive kind of potential foot guns here
that it is possible to write our code
that like looks like one thing and does
something completely different uh and
I don't know I guess it's sort of a
language of like personal responsibility
as a language it doesn't provide as many
guard roles as other languages and so
you basically have to adopt conventions
and I think mostly that works because
um like folks aren't going to develop
these you're not going to develop this
kind of complex you're not going to take
advantage of these uh complex language
features as a data scientist you're just
going to use packages that take
advantage of them in that kind of Scopes
the problem down I think to be much more
manageable
yeah no that makes that makes sense
another another question that came in um
not from the YouTube chat but on Discord
somebody was asking
um for maybe for someone who's never
programmed an art before and and thus
hasn't used shiny
um you talked before about sort of
building the shiny version in in Python
and they're asking about what are some
of the advantages that shiny brings uh
that maybe a visualization or dashboard
tool like dash for example um in the
python ecosystem
um yeah so why do we need shiny for
python I think is the concise way yeah
that's a really good question I think it
comes down to this idea of reactivity
like if you're creating something simple
with like a pretty straightforward
linear flow like streamlit with Dash a
really really easy to use like really
easy to get up and running with with
shiny like to use shiny effectively you
have to learn a little bit about this
reactive programming model
and it's basically our belief that like
if you put in some like legitimately
hard work doing that that's really going
to pay off like when you start to create
like much much much more complex apps
where there are like many changing
inputs and mini intermediate
calculations and many results that this
the way that reactivity reactivity Works
allows you to kind of create these
things that just don't turn up and turn
into this like nightmare spaghetti of
like events changing things and then you
can change one thing and sometimes
things change that you don't want to
change and other times things don't
change when they should reactivity is
just such a great model for solving that
problem that we believe that a little
bit of investment the air kind of pays
off in the long run
foreign
yeah no that makes total sense
um
often there's so many good questions the
other one coming in around you know you
talked before about how so much of your
experience has been in the in the our
ecosystem and now that the sort of
transition to also building tools and
other ecosystems has
um has happened what are some of those
areas of friction that you see in the
python space and and I'm sure some of
the open source projects that you talked
about today are actually helping address
some of those things but any other ones
that you're you're top of mind at the
moment
yeah I mean it's hot and it's hard for
me to answer this without being cruel
it's a python but just just like when I
look at python code it just seems like
there's so many opportunities to like
Express things
like I mean and some of these things
like you just can't do better in Python
like the limitation of the language
being
and the tools like pandas have to like
really jump really have to fight against
the language to give you this fluid
syntax uh upper data manipulation
and then not to mention like this whole
like coming from our community this
whole kind of like virtual environment
thing it's just you know how much I know
like I only really not like I don't
really know about
these people like like convincing about
it on on Twitter but like certainly the
fact that and I just don't have to worry
about that most the time but that seems
really cool so like I don't know I don't
have any like
um things like in mind currently like
certainly over the years I've learned a
lot from the python ecosystem I think
there's a lot of the Python ecosystem
can learn from our and I think really my
message is like
it's so easy when you go from something
that's comfortable to you to something
that's new and it's strange
it's just so easy at least it's so easy
for me to be like no that's like wrong
like it's not different it's wrong it's
bad and I don't want to do it and I
think the more you can like kind of
fight that like programming language
xenophobia like the more you can fight
that to to cultivate like curiosity like
oh that's that's strange like I wonder
why they do that I think that's such a
such a powerful mindset to kind of learn
from from others and it's it's hard work
and it takes a while to kind of take
Port these ideas from an environment
that's quite different to your own
environment I I think it's so so
valuable
yeah and I appreciate that about your
um about your talk with sort of
introducing these ideas and R that might
sort of be a little bit uh different for
people who are maybe coming from a
different programming ecosystem before
so I think that's a a very important
thing to highlight
um Ben's asking about was there a hint
that maybe a crayon for python is coming
and I'll build on this very slightly as
well just for somebody who's doesn't
have our experience what where do people
publish packages if they can't meet that
sort of high bar that's being set out by
Grand like is there like a unofficial
sort of package registry that people put
their stuff into
yeah so if you do if you can't get your
package on the crayon you basically just
publish it to to GitHub there's no like
repository but there's tools that make
it pretty easy to install it and compile
it from Source uh there are there are
other projects uh like our universe uh
and to kind of a lesser extent drought
so drat lets you build your own kind of
repository so you can automate building
the binaries that people could store
them themselves and our universe is a
hosted service that will do that do that
for you
uh but absolutely no hints that we will
be building something like a crowd for
python just like I I I cut this like
this year I feel like this year hubris
of like trying to solve the packaging
problem this year but for python we're
like so many people have tried and
failed before and if you don't succeed
you just make the problem worse because
now there's like one more packaging
Solution that's people need to to hear
about so I think like as I've uh matured
as a programmer I have learned that
sometimes it's better just not to to
tackle things because if you fail the
witch is likely in many complex problems
you just make the problem worse
yeah no I love that that's a great uh a
great piece of wisdom
um another question coming in and I'm
sure this is somebody that you get all
the time because people love our studio
as sort of the interface so much any
thoughts around a a python version of
that
yeah I mean that's a that seems like a
very obvious thing for for us to work on
I think we would love to bring to python
users like they're kind of same like
batteries included uh experience we
deliver to our users uh no like concrete
plans for that currently but certainly
seems uh like that would be a great
benefit to the broader data science
community
it's just kind of like a an anecdote to
that like interestingly like it took me
quite a like like I I used ah for quite
a few years before uh our studio existed
and the reason I actually started using
rstudio was as our latex editor because
uh JJ who wrote our studio had put all
the effort in to make latex just work
like I had spent something like I don't
know like three days trying to configure
Sublime Text to have like really good
latex supports or just automatically
installed packages and just like worked
and gave you log files and stuff and I
failed and then like our studio I tried
it now studio and it just worked and so
for a long time I used our studio as my
my latex editor and then eventually I
slowly transitioned to using it for
everything
I love that
um a question coming in from David uh
around the potential of a of an R Studio
slash pause that conference in Europe
yeah I think we would
like I I am like so
ambivalent about this because like I'm
the one yes that would be like awesome
and I would love that would be so much
fun
uh to like go to that and speak at that
with my like conference organizing hat
on I'm like oh God that'd be like twice
as much work
um so I think it's something like we
would love to do we're trying to think
about ways of doing it that um not twice
as much work
um
you know maybe doing some like satellite
events or work with some of our partners
in Europe to do sort of mixtures of of
uh of conference hybrid conferences in
some way unlikely to happen next year
but definitely something we would love
to do in the future
yeah no that makes a lot of sense I'm
I'll I think I'll end with this final
question just because we have um another
speaker coming in soon but
um you know just in in hindsight looking
back over maybe the last 10 years and
and seeing the growth of the our
community and the python community and
and all the other languages that have
been coming up do you think that um and
maybe this is and this isn't meant to be
a tricky question but do you think like
uh you know for positive R Studio
they're like you all maybe should have
transitioned sooner to this future of
multi-lingual or was it what was really
the sort of
pivotal moment where you're like okay
now is the time that we want to dive in
and do this and maybe before it wasn't
it didn't make sense um but now it makes
sense
I I don't think there's like some
I don't know like I don't think there's
some
like sort of
switch I'm like right I just think like
like over time
like I I think like first of all as a
company like we kind of believe that to
to do good work like you're better off
being focused on one thing like you're
better off like focusing killing that
and then like moving on killing a good
good way doing a really good job of it
and then moving on uh to the to the kind
of the next thing so in some ways I I
think the um
I don't want to be like arrogant enough
to apply that with like solved every
problem and ah there's still many many
for us to tackle but it just felt like
we're doing like we've done a really
good job in our like let's tackle let's
what's the next challenge
but let's Embrace another a big
Challenge and see what we can do there
yeah no I love that Hadley this was
awesome it was so wonderful to have you
give this talk
um and I I think the the community uh
got a ton from the discussion so very
much appreciated if folks want to
connect with Hadley he's on Twitter
maybe uh maybe some other places online
as well so appreciate you being here
Hadley too thanks so much for having me
bye everyone yeah of course